you know I'm not sure this is going to
work unless Warner Brothers figures out
a way to obliviate the memory of the
original film series
[Music]
hey folks I'm gonna do something I
haven't done in a long time
which is talk about the Harry Potter
franchise
and not talk about JK Rowling
now before I get into this and let me
make it very clear I am on the record
repeatedly in many places uh as having
massive issues with JK Rowling and
frankly I don't think anybody should be
supporting her products or anything that
is attached to her name at this point
but that is well established about me
and it's definitely not the focus of
this video I'm actually strictly going
to be speaking about the Harry Potter
property as a property and in terms of
what has leaked that appears to be the
next phase of plans for what Warner
Brothers wants to do with that property
and what those plans say about the state
of it because I find that very
interesting and I don't need to get into
all the issues with the original Creator
in order to talk about this so
while I am certainly no champion of
Harry Potter uh keep in mind that at
this point I'm going to be having this
conversation about what we have found
out that Warner Brothers seems to be
planning and my thoughts on it and they
basically have nothing to do with her
so what was found out
well while it has not been confirmed yet
and from what I can tell only because
contracts have not been finalized but
what has been reported by multiple
generally pretty reliable sources that
is always important to know like some
Outlets are more reliable than others
but Fairly reliable ones that at least
seem to have better vetting than some of
the less scrupulous ones have been
reporting that HBO under Warner Brothers
is uh attempting to finalize a deal to
do a TV series adaptation of the
original seven Harry Potter books with
the intention of doing a full season per
book They're basically kind of pulling a
Game of Thrones on it is what they
appear to be trying to do
and as I said I think this says some
very interesting things about the
current state of the franchise because
to kind of skip to the end a little bit
this reads like a desperation move and
me saying that just has to do with how
Harry Potter is currently working out
for Warner Brothers which is not as well
as they would like
they don't like to bring it up now but
when the Fantastic Beasts series of film
started there were supposed to be five
of them there won't be I will be shocked
if they do a fourth one because every
single one of those three films had a
200 million dollar budget That's not
including the marketing so who knows
what they actually spent on it but each
one made notably less money than the one
before first one pulled in over 800
million so I won't pulled in a bit over
six third one it was about 400 million
it was dropping by significant
increments and it was costing them the
same amount of money to do it every time
you don't keep doing that that's once
you get to the third one and it is
dropped off by even more than it dropped
off from the first to the second you
don't continue that trajectory maybe you
do the third one and they did because
you hope well maybe people just didn't
like the second one as much and the
third one's better maybe they'll come
back whether or not it's better I don't
know I never watched that one because by
then all the stuff for the rolling came
out but
um that was probably their hope in doing
the third Fantastic Beasts but
it it didn't it made even less and so it
would be a very foolish thing for them
to continue on with that franchise given
the complete downward trajectory that
the returns have had on that
what else do they have
well I'm sure they would love
love nothing more than to get back the
core original cast Daniel Radcliffe and
Emma Watson and Rupert Grint and have
them come back and do a film version of
the cursed child that's the play sort of
The Unofficial eighth Harry Potter book
but that was the play that was done
um in the UK and that's not gonna happen
I mean first of all I never I don't
think I ever talked about it I might
have I can't remember if I ever talked
about that play on here I have read it
it's it's
quite bad like and I don't and I don't
even mean like just in terms of oh and
it ruined characters like no just
narratively structurally it's it's a
mess and it breaks the established rules
of the universe really badly it's not a
good story but if they could re-get
regain reassemble
kept trying I know I find the word
reassemble that original cast that might
be enough of a selling point to be able
to get away with the movie adaptation of
that play
that won't work however because it is
very difficult to imagine that all of
them would be willing to come back
especially Daniel Radcliffe what this
point is spoken out directly in
opposition to JK Rowling's uh statements
and has even been doing work I believe
with the Trevor Project lately
he's made his stance pretty clear and
while yes he did come back for sort of
the anniversary celebration thing that
was on HBO that was more reminiscing of
what he'd already done and I would not
take that as an indicator of what he's
going to do in future especially given
the uh kind of roles the guy's been
taking he clearly doesn't take a role
just because while I need the money he's
had a very eclectic filmography since
Harry Potter ended he seems to do what
he wants to do and now I given
everything going on I have a hard time
believing that he would want to come
back and do this and since he doesn't
seem to be someone who does something
just for the money I don't think they
get him
I don't think they get Emma Watson
either River Clinton maybe but if
they're not going to get all three back
there would be no point that would be
the big pitch of doing the cursed child
so they can't do the cursed child
there's really not any good Financial
Prospect in doing more fantastic Beast
movies there is the Hogwarts Legacy
video game which did do very well but a
couple things about that the first is
that video games take a long time to
make and develop and unless you start
cranking them out on an assembly line in
which case you end up with garbage and
people catch on to that dang quick
usually then I it's gonna be another
four or five years before they can get
one of those and they need other stuff
out the door to justify them continuing
to pay the licensing fee for the Harry
Potter IP that's the first thing the
other thing is I do have to wonder if
over at Warner Brothers if some of them
are afraid that when they eventually get
around to another Harry Potter video
game if they're not a little worried
about a repeat of the Fantastic Beasts
thing because what appears to have
happened if I were to just sort of sit
back and make a guess as to the general
sense of disinterest there is yes
obviously just the stuff with rolling
but again we're not dealing with that
but beyond that the Fantastic Beasts
movies the first one obviously that was
kind of exciting like ooh different
aspects of this world a lot of people
came and saw that and it was okay there
was some potential not as many people
came back the second time that did even
less coherent stuff with the potential
and the concepts and then people didn't
even bother coming back to the third one
there is a possibility that Hogwarts
Legacy got as big a boost and did as
well as it did for the novelty there has
not been a game like that set in the
World of Harry Potter set in Hogwarts
and on novelty alone just getting to
play that kind of game and that kind of
setting
that carries a lot of weight
whether or not the rest of it is so good
that people will come back even after
the novelty is worn off they won't know
until they get to another one
and maybe not and even if people do come
back in the same kind of numbers like I
said
four or five years if they're going to
take the time to fully develop maybe a
little bit less maybe maybe more in the
three year time span if they end up
reusing a lot of assets from the first
one I suppose there's that but again
that's longer than Warner Brothers will
want to wait to get Returns on this now
here's the funny thing about doing a TV
adaptation of the books
taking the full context of everything
else out just as an adaptation
that's probably a better way to adapt
those books
because the movies as beloved as they
are had to cut a lot and a lot of stuff
that was cut is the sort of thing that a
TV series has the breathing room to do
mainly I'm talking about the classroom
stuff the Dynamics of the students you
know separate from the major plot beats
getting to know more of the student body
more of the professors just spending
more time in a day to day and not just
dealing with only the major bullet
points especially in the latter ones of
here's the major crisis so we got to
deal with all that stuff we're gonna
have time for class stuff you can
practically forget that they're even in
a school in the first place because of
the confines of a movie run time and a
TV series would give them the breathing
room to have all that stuff in and while
you could argue that that stuff wasn't
strictly necessarily necessary to the
plots which obviously wasn't the movies
managed to get by without a lot of it
but it was part of the flavor of those
books and keep in mind before everything
went to hell with rolling I was a fan of
those books so like I can appreciate
that those things have
and the ability to bring those in and
add them into the mix and give it a more
fleshed out and lived-in field than the
movies would be able to do
that is probably potentially assuming
you get um Good People attached to it
going to lead to a better adaptation of
the original work that captures more of
what is appealing about it than the
movies would be able to do
it still reads as a desperation move
though because here's the thing
the movies
while some of them have aged better than
others the the first two don't hold up
very well and I think some of them are
overrated but as a whole collectively
those eight films
they're beloved
and remaking something that's beloved
that is tricky especially when the thing
that's beloved is an adaptation that is
praised for its accuracy because like I
said while the TV show adaptation could
bring in what was cut
in terms of what we've already seen
there isn't a lot that they could do to
make it more book accurate for the
things it did adapt
and so you'll have more
but will it be better
and when it comes to remakes and reboots
doing it on something that is beloved is
treacherous
and I know it can seem
a little bit like a long time since the
films ended but it wasn't that long ago
I think it was 2010 the last one came
out so right now we're look we're coming
on 13 years and that is not an
insignificant amount of time and we've
certainly had a reboots in shorter time
frames than that look at all the
Spider-Man reboots but here's the thing
about something like the Spider-Man
reboots they happen as quickly as they
did because the ones that were left
behind to then be rebooted again either
had fallen apart on hard times or just
whenever that beloved to begin with what
I mean by that is while there is a hell
of a lot of love for the first two Toby
Maguire's Spider-Man 3 rubbed so many
people the wrong way that wow the reboot
did feel like that came really fast
it also kind of made sense to a certain
degree but then the Amazing Spider-Man
neither of those movies was really that
great and so rebooting again and being
like just just try again because there
wasn't a definitive iconic adaptation of
Spider-Man
so you could do something else besides
which Spider-Man by his nature because
the character has been reinvented so
much in the comics over time you can
pull from different core sources like
the same room wasn't very much an
adaptation of the 60s and 70s era of
Spider-Man and uh The Amazing Spider-Man
feels a bit more akin to some of the 90s
stuff uh in a lot of ways while still
having him in high school which they
shouldn't have done but that's a tangent
and then Tom Holland sort of brought it
up to a more modern sensibility and so
there was a different fundamental feel
but again those movies
captured the feel
of the books
almost perfectly in terms of again what
they did choose to adapt
why are they doing this because
there is no way that they are going to
be able to put these out there and not
have them compared to the movies
potentially unfavorably especially if
any of the core cast is not as good and
you need to realize people are going to
have massive Nostalgia blinders on for
that original series of films So Not
only would the new cast have to be uh as
good they'd have to be significantly
better because they have to overcome not
only the talent of the original cast
both the students and the teachers but
they're going to have to overcome
people's Nostalgia for them
and
while
I would expect that a first season of a
Harry Potter show would probably do
gangbusters
I'd also wonder how fast would it drop
off
because a first season you know people
with zeep how's it different what's new
how are the new actors but then once you
know unless you decide it's all better
than the original
why would you come back
you know how it happens
are they ever going to get anybody to
play Snape as iconically as Alan Rickman
did could there ever be a McGonagall as
iconic as Maggie Smith
I mean this is part of why I think the
smartest thing that Amazon Prime did
when doing its Lord of the Rings series
whatever you think of that I think one
of the smartest things they did was to
deal vastly with unknown characters and
characters we hadn't seen before because
how do you recast Gandalf
I don't know if you'd be able to do it
and it's not because nobody else could
be good in the part
but
Ian McKellen so beloved in that role
how's it ever going to be worth trying
and that's kind of where the Harry
Potter films are at
for a lot of fans casual and hardcore
like those films got as many people into
Harry Potter as the books themselves did
some people started with the movies and
then found the books plenty people got
came to the books first but like the two
they fed into each other they built each
other up
so
why am I saying this is a desperation
move and why are they doing it if it
seems like a bit of an artistically
doomed
thing because
the healthiest thing artistically for
this thing to do would be to add in the
kind of material that was cut but also
take some notable differences some
notable changes in character maybe even
in plot so that it can be its own thing
and not just be we're remaking the
movies but it's like we're adding in a
season of Television worth of deleted
scenes because
who's gonna stick around for that for
more than a season I mean some people
will but not as many for how is it for
how expensive it's going to be to try
and do this
so
why
as I said the reboot just seems like you
have not given enough time for the films
to kind of fade if they ever will
they're doing it because what the hell
else are they going to do at this point
they tried spinning off new stories set
in the same world with Fantastic Beasts
diminishing returns almost immediately
the video game thing as I said has its
own hurdles in terms of how long it
takes and that may or may not result in
diminishing returns as well what do you
do because the thing you need to
remember is that when you are talking
about the mentalities of corporate
executives
they run kind of the same way an
algorithm does almost entirely on
precedent they will make a decision
based off what worked before and what
didn't work over you know past the first
one was a new series of films with
different characters okay that didn't
work
the video games maybe they'll get more
out of it but they need to milk this
property for more than just video games
if they're gonna get their full money's
worth out of it and they need to assure
their investors that they are doing
something with these properties that is
why when James gone announced his plans
for the DC Universe it was like five
years worth of plans and he said oh I
haven't even told you everything like I
expressed my concern that as much as I
like James Gunn and I like a fair amount
of what he said he wants to do with it
that's a lot and I immediately got
flashbacks to back when Man of Steel
came out and then Warner Brothers
announced at the time five years worth
of films
you know what else they had announced
around that same time
at that same Time Warner Brothers had
said we're not doing mid-budget movies
anymore we are doing blockbuster movies
only and we're doing them related to
three properties DC superheroes
Harry Potter
and Lego
because the Lego movie had come out and
been a huge Smash Hit
what happened to that third one what
happened
to the Lego franchise
diminishing returns happened
The Lego Movie happened people loved it
were annoyed at its Oscar snub it made
huge money
then they did Lego Batman also very good
great even made a little bit less money
then they did Lego Ninjago maybe not a
great idea critics didn't really care
for that one made even less money and
then they released The Lego Movie 2.
which was the we have to make sure this
property is still viable move
because when the spin-offs that you've
been doing are starting to you do a new
entry in the original friend in the
original sort of pillar franchise within
this
to reignite things remind people why
they love it and just give the whole
thing a kick in the rear and then Lego
Movie part two underperformed
they made their money back but it did
not hit original Lego Movie numbers it
didn't even really come that close
and after that
they let the right slaps they said screw
it
The Lego Movie part 2 should have been
big on the scale of the first one and
the fact that we made a direct sequel to
the biggest hit within this thing and it
still made even less money we need to
walk away because this entire thing is
now diminishing returns
they are potentially in a similar
position
with Harry Potter right now
because the spin-offs
nosedive I can't imagine they're looking
to try and do more spin-offs because
these films are expensive because of the
effects and the creatures and the magic
and and they often get very big names to
be in these so they can't cheaply try
and do another spin-off
there as I said the video games but
there's the potential for more
diminishing returns there they would
have loved to do the Kershaw because
that could have that could have been the
kick in the rib for the whole franchise
because we brought the team back
together but as I said I will be shocked
if they would ever be able to do that in
fact I would almost be willing to bet
money that they probably have sent out
feelers to see if those uh core three
actors would be willing to come back and
they got turned down by at least one if
not all of them and that is why they are
moving now
to the TV series
because when you can't milk spin-offs
and you need more than this one other
Avenue that being the video games
then what is there to do go back to what
we know Works what we know made all the
money which was the original seven books
but you can't remake those as movies
cause dang what would you even say is
going to be different or better even
vaguely what is there to pitch
oh well we'll do it as a TV show because
like we can we can have full seasons and
like it'll be more stuff like yeah it'll
be more
but that's why I say it's a desperation
move this is Warner Brothers coming in
and going okay what is the thing that we
can do that is the closest to the thing
that made us all the money back when we
decided to go all in on this well the
thing that made them all the money were
the original adaptations
so re-adapt the original work again
and I'm going to make a prediction right
now
if this moves forward if this TV show
happens and if
it is not successful enough to finish
its run
if it doesn't get a full Seven Seasons
if the expense of producing it is so
much that it's not worth it for the
ratings they're getting to do the full
seven seasons and cover all seven books
if that happens
Warner Brothers will let the rights uh
return to JK Rowling and they'll let it
go
this is the this is the franchise's last
chance to prove to Warner Brothers that
it will continue to sustain them and
they need it to do that part of the
reason that they are announcing this
much as I said is in regards to
shareholders because there's a lot of
concerns about Warner Brothers or Warner
Brothers Discovery now because the news
headlines for a while have been all the
stuff they've been doing that's been
ticking people off
canceling stuff canceling the reliefs of
entire movies like Batgirl gutting stuff
like all these planned Scooby-Doo movies
some of which were already finished the
uh canceling of all these shows
completely reorganizing HBO Max merging
it with Discovery plus layoffs removal
of stuff from the streaming service
all these things just look bad and while
on paper maybe they look okay because
they're cutting costs like nobody's been
excited
for what they've been up to
until they could start announcing a
bunch of new stuff for the properties
they have access to that people love so
first we had DC and it wasn't enough for
James Gunn to say what's coming in the
next few years he had to announce five
years worth of stuff very packed five
years worth of stuff
and I'm sure that pressure came because
they need to reassure the shareholders
that they're not letting these
properties sit idle and they are they
are gonna make back all of the weird
wonkiness that has gone wrong they're
going to make back not only the money
but the good will
and Harry Potter's their other big major
franchise that they actually know what
to do with because Warner Brothers owns
a whole lot of other stuff that they
could be doing things with that they
just have never figured out what to do
with they haven't figured out what to do
with Looney Tunes in decades so you know
there's other stuff that they have but
as I said
they're thinking based off precedent
what was the stuff that made us the most
money Harry Potter is one of those
things
but the fact that they're talking about
or trying to get or negotiating or
trying to finalize just adapting the
books again
that to me says a lot about the state of
Warner Brothers and the viability of
milking more money out of these things
and that's not me saying Harry Potter is
going to disappear I don't expect it to
anytime soon people still love the books
people still love the movies
so it's not like it's suddenly going to
fade away
but for an entity like Warner Brothers
to have it be worth them paying the
licensing fee for it
they can't just be pulling in residuals
from people streaming the movies or even
what they pull off the video game they
need to have new stuff in the pipeline
they need to be growing the brand needs
to be getting bigger and if it's not
they'll drop it
they've been dropping a lot of stuff
the only reason they haven't dropped
this is because this has been one of
their biggest things but if they can't
make it one of their biggest things
again with the TV show assuming it
happens
they'll let it go
and I just thought it was interesting to
think about and talk through where
things are at for this property largely
in terms of like adaptations and money
making potential like creatively I think
the property has done
whatever it was going to do that was
worth having
because as I said I didn't think the
first fantastic Beast was great I really
thought the second one was a mess I
didn't see the third one but
you know
the original series is beloved it will
remain so the original movies are
beloved and will remain so
but that's a complete story
and it's unlike say the
comic book related stuff where you can
always adapt another specific story you
can always adapt another era
this is just the one story
and the spin-offs didn't work
we'll see where it goes
and whether or not I'll ever talk about
it again I don't know I'll probably be
watching out of morbid curiosity if this
moves forward for things like casting
directors show Runners Etc I won't watch
it if it happens let's be very clear
about that
um you know for the reasons I already
mentioned about Ms Rowling but we're not
going back down that rabbit hole I've
set my piece now on Harry Potter itself
and on the potential for a TV series
what are your thoughts on any of this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills allows me to do this as
my living even if you can to help me out
that way although you know there's nice
things there's Early Access to videos
there's a Discord there's stuff like
that but even if you can't
like share subscribe help me out but
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time trans women
or women trans men are men non-binary
people are non-binary and this council
is adjourned
[Music]
my thanks to all my patrons but in
particular I want to thank Robin Moore
Zubin lotfulla Sarvis to rock the thing
that goes doing in the anime Ruth Oliver
B solitary pictures
ulurik bogudan Melinda Walters imudelki
Leo the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky
Sparks fernandby likes the poodle Robin
Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim
price Adam RDL Taylor goddess Elita
Elida not sure ah David Hall Shayla
Gourley Rosalind Bennett you want to
hear me mess up your name too it's in
the patreon perks
I gotta work on that
[Music]